non
bakou
[Musique]
ce qu'il a pour elle
comme vous venez d'un télé crochet ce
soir on va accueillir les chroniqueurs
ils sont tous en télé crochet dans des
membres de télé crochet on va accueillir
d'abord un groupe qui a fait qui a été
formé à la première saison de popstars
c'était quoi le groupe première saison
ouais c'était les l5
[Musique]
le cas
je suis content
vous pouvez en faire votre danse à macau
[Musique]
il a remporté la saison 5 de la nouvelle
star c'est qu'ils saison 5 de la
nouvelle star la nouvelle bien dorées
julien doré qu'il est fort il est avec
nous ce soir je viendrai
[Applaudissements]
j'ai passé
oui
[Applaudissements]
à
le souci des détails regarder la
barrette d'action foutu tout la centrale
et version pour les inconnus dans
popstars saison 3 les lignes ah oui
dans ce groupe on appelait des linkup ah
oui aller il y avait ma foi bien sûr
[Musique]
le soir les pieds
mais
[Musique]
c est moi y'a le ringard du siècle ce
groupe n'a ni queue ni tête
wesh wesh alors oui ce n'est donc c'est
lionel tim vous vous êtes autisme et on
dirait sur lyonnais on dira m 1 persiste
à l'alpe d'huez là là je vous le dis ça
fait partie de mon top 5 de mes chansons
préférées de ma vie entière
non je suis comme un ouf sur cette
chanson c'est une des chansons préférées
aussi de celui qui va camper ce
personnage c'est ma cousine en fait ils
chantent oui c'est sheryfa luna
je n'avais pas
à
je le laisse
la nuit
et c'est
en quelle année chez rita du nike
habillé comme ça parce que là je ne
comprends pas je rêvais il ya quinze
jours l'été un peu comme ça c'est un peu
dommage
ouais ouais c'est pas
[Musique]